fortement mobiliser l'été pour venir en
aide aux baigneur en difficulté les
pompiers se forment aussi au sauvetage
en cas de crue et d'inondation en
Indre-et-Loire en compte une trentaine
de plongeurs spécialisés mais tous les
pompiers doivent être capables de sauver
des vies et les mises en situation sont
parfois spectaculaires comme vous allez
le voir dans ce reportage à Tours de
Romainville la formation de sauvetage
aquatique comprend deux volets tout
d'abord l'intervention en eau vive dans
l’hypothèse d'un phénomène de forte crue
premier exercice la lecture de courant
dans la rivière de contournement du Cher
mis à disposition par la métropole il
arrive au niveau du point isolé
là il se tourne et il attend le
contre-courant voilà il se fait aspirer
tout de suite autre exercice lié au
risque inondations dans un cadre urbain
le sauvetage d'une personne piégée par
les eaux dans sa voiture qui sécurise ta
victime donc là on part dans l'option
qu'elle peut pas descendre du véhicule
d'accord donc tu viendras te mettre en
position sur le véhicule et pour que
l'exercice soit le plus réaliste
possible et sans danger pour les
pompiers en formation un véhicule
prototype unique en France a été
spécialement conçu par les élèves du
lycée Gustave Eiffel nos cap métallier
ont créé toute la tubulure et les
chaudronniers ont créé toute la
structure et l'habillage de de cette
voiture avec des méthodes et des outils
qu'ils ont à leur disposition au sein du
lycée en cas d'inondation dans la ville
80 cm d'eau suffisent à emporter un être
humain pour les sauveteurs s'ajoutent
les difficultés
lié au mobilier urbain les bancs publics
les poteaux également les voitures mais
aussi les bouches d'égouts qui vont donc
les égouts qui vont se remplir d'eau et
là les bouches des goûts vont se
soulever et là on va pouvoir retrouver
des phénomènes de siphon et si on parle
de siphon ensuite on pourra retrouver
des phénomènes de marmite avec des
bouches d'égo qui qui bouillonnent et le
risque de se faire aspirer justement
dans ce phénomène de siphon d'où
l'importance de ces formations très
spécifiques pour les pompiers pour
acquérir les bons réflexes et faire face
aux imprévus